The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So last time we
talked about how to describe
say for the boundary CFT is at
a finite temperature what would
be its gravity description?
So what we described
was a thermal theory.
Say a Thermal CFT on
the flat space, OK?
We show that this is related
to a black hole with a planar
horizon.
The key is that the horizon
should have the same topology
as the boundary space.
So in terms of the picture
this is your boundary,
so this is z equal to 0, and
then the horizon somewhere say,
at some value of z0.
So horizon has some value
of z0 and then the horizon
have the same topology
as the boundary on space.
And then you can do some of
the [? lamicks, ?] et cetera.
Any questions about that?
Good.
So previously we also
briefly discussed
that the Ads also allow
you to put the field
theory on the sphere.
So if you put the field
theory on the sphere
then that will be due
to the global Ads.
Now you can ask
the same question.
What happens if we put the
boundary theory on the sphere
and then put there the
finite temperature.
So let us put a
CFT on the sphere
at the finite temperature.
So the story here is much
richer for a very simple reason.
For a very simple reason.
So if you have a CFT just on the
Rd minus 1 so this Rd minus 1,
this euclidean space,
euclidean flat space
does not have a scale and the
CFT does not have a scale.
So if you put it at
a finite temperature
then the temperature
is the only scale,
and essentially provide
a unit over the scale.
So the temperature
is the only scale,
so essentially providing
an energy unit.
So this means that for CFT on
the finite temperature, CFT,
on the flat space then
physics at all temperatures
are the same.
So they are just related
by a scaling of units.
So in some sense you can see it
seems that the physics is very
simple whether you
have like 0.0001 degree
or you have 10,000
degrees, doesn't matter.
And it's only the relative
scale that matters.
So the physics at all
temperatures is the same.
There's no difference
between the low temperature
and the high temperature,
and the temperature just
provide the units.
But if you put the
CFT on the sphere
now the story's different.
So for CFT on the sphere because
the sphere has a side itself.
OK, so let's take the
sphere have both sides r.
Again when you put
the CFT on the sphere
the sides of the sphere does
not matter because again
the sides of the
sphere are essentially
provide by the units because the
theory's getting [? warrant. ?]
So let's just put all
the sides to be r.
So let's take sides to be r.
And the r can be
chosen to be the same
as the curvature radius
in the [? back ?]
just to make formula
simple, and you
can choose it to be any radius.
And now since the sphere
already have [? all ?] sides
and now you put it at
a finite temperature.
Now you have the
dimensionless number.
Then at the finite
temperature in the physics
is controlled by a
dimensionless number, r times t.
So now the temperature
makes a difference.
Now different
temperature that r is
is different because now
you have a relative scale
and if rt is small
then essentially you're
at the low temperature,
and then when rt is big
then you have a
high temperature.
Now there's a
dimensionless number
to characterize whether
you're in the low temperature
or in the high temperature.
So the physics essentially
become much richer because
of the and then you have a
you have a whole parameter
the physics can depend on.
And so indeed the story
become rather intricate
whether we can see
the finite temperature
theory on the sphere
so now let me just
mention some important features.
So I will walk you not too
slowly but also not too quickly
about the physics on the sphere.
We cannot afford to do it
very slowly at this time.
Yeah, but if I do
it too quickly,
of course you won't
learn anything.
OK, so let me just point
out some important features.
So first, when we
talked about the story
last week-- when we talked
about the finite temperature
on the flat space-- we
said, oh, probably there
are two possible descriptions
for finite temperature
theory from the
[? back ?] point of view.
So one is that you can
have a thermal gas.
You have a thermal gas in Ads.
But then we argue
that for a theory
on the sphere that's
not allowed because you
encompass singularity because
the metric becomes singular.
And the one big difference
for the theory on the sphere
is that actually
now this is allowed.
So the thermal gas in
Ads is now allowed.
So now let's go
through the argument.
So now first let me just write
down the global Ads metric.
Of course you can write in
many different coordinates.
So the most
convenient coordinates
to write global Ads for our
purpose is the following.
So this is just a pure Ads
and r goes to 0 to infinite.
So this is like somewhat
analog of a, say,
sprinkle coordinate
in flat space.
But the difference
is of course now
you have nontrivial
factors which tell
you're in the curve space time.
So now to go to
the thermal Ads we
do the trick you normally
do for thermal field theory.
Is that you go to
euclidean space
and then you put
the euclidean time
to be periodic in the
inverse temperature.
Actually, let me write
down here the analogous
metric on the sphere.
So this is a situation
we can see that
before for the theory on the
flat space, on the plane,
and then that would be the
metric to be on the sphere.
So we've talked about
last time if you
make tau to be
periodic then as z
goes to infinity then this
circle shrink to zero sides.
Because the prefactor goes to 0.
So the tau circle
will have a sides beta
but the proper densities
controlled by the prefactor.
And because when z goes to
infinity then the proper lens
of the circle goes to 0.
So whenever you have a
circle we shrink to 0
then you have a singular
behavior, et cetera,
and then the metric's singular.
So you can have [? where ?]
it is a singular behavior
and so that's why this
is not the amount.
But now in this case, when you
do such energy configuration
this becomes well defined.
Because of the proper sides
of the tau circle so now you
local proper lens local proper
sides over the tau circle,
it's just given by
this prefactor 1 plus
r squared divided by 1
squared by r squared beta.
And since a greater
equal here so
this is greater equal to beta.
So actually this is
bounded from below.
So this is a circle [? label ?]
will become too small.
Essentially the minimal
side of the circle
is the same as the beta itself.
So this euclidean metric
is perfectly well defined.
OK, so euclidean
metric well defined.
So you can trust here that the
euclidean metric is singular
as z goes to infinity.
If you put the 0 in
the flat space then
that's not allowed but
in this case allowed.
So for the serial
in the sphere--
but still there's an analog
of a black hole solution.
You can also find
the black hole.
Again you just write
down the standards,
sprinkle's metric answers,
for black hole metric
and then you solve
Einstein equation,
then you find-- so let me
just write down the answer.
So you find that this space also
allows a black hole solution.
Can be written as the following.
So now f just slight
generalization of this factor.
So the mu is primarily
related to black hole mass.
And the horizon is that
i equal to r0 and r
satisfy that this
factor goes to 0.
So you can also find out what
is temperature associated
with this black hole.
So here that beta
can be anything.
There's no constraint
on the beta.
So here using the standard
technique to find what
is the Hawking temperature
for this black hole.
Let me just write
down the answer.
So this is just 4 pi
divided by f prime.
You've already add to the
horizon standard formula
and you just find
the 0 of this guy,
and then you just
take the derivative
so you find the beta can
be written in terms of r0
as follows.
So this is just
a simple algebra.
So you find that if you
take the derivative,
we express the
derivative is r0, then
you find the Hawking temperature
of the following form.
I'm not doing this
calculation here.
You can use it to
check yourself.
Good, any questions so far?
So now it seems like
we have a problem.
Because we have a
black hole we also
have a standard thermal Ads.
Then which one is
the right description
for the field theory at
the finite temperature?
Seems like we have a choice.
But now if you look
at this function
the story's even more
tricky than that.
So this product of this function
this is a rough behavior
of this function.
So this is the
inverse temperature
and then this is the
sides of the horizon.
And the side of the
horizon essentially
determines your entropy.
So it's really a
physical thing here
and because of the area over
the horizon it's the entropy.
The area of the
horizon is a entropy.
So this r0 it can be considered
as something standard
for entropy.
So now just to
get the intrusion,
this is a complicated
function, it's
because intrusion and
how this beta depend
on this r0, the horizon side.
Suppose horizon side is
very small, r0 goes to 0,
then downstairs is finite.
Upstairs goes to 0
so you just go to 0.
And the r0 is very
large so the downstairs
proportionate to r0
square but upstairs only
proportionate to r0 so
when r0 is very large
we go to 0 as the r0.
And this is a small
function so there
must be a maximum somewhere.
And because you can easily
find the maximum just
to take the derivative
of that function.
Anyway, so that's how the
beta will depend on r.
But now this plot
is highly peculiar.
Why?
Can you tell me why?
There's a maximum on
theta, which means?
That's right.
So there's a beta max.
So that means this is a beta
max which tells you there's
a minimum temperature.
That means that black
hole solution only
exist above a certain
minimal temperature.
And you can easily find out
what is that minimal temperature
just by taking the
derivative of this function
and it require to be 0.
Is there any other thing
peculiar regarding this plot?
AUDIENCE: When r0--
PROFESSOR: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: When r0,
[INAUDIBLE] black hole.
PROFESSOR: Well, r0 is
0-- the black hole becomes
smaller and smaller.
It means there's no black hole.
AUDIENCE: But the
temperature is infinity.
PROFESSOR: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: But the temperature
there is infinity.
That's weird.
PROFESSOR: No, that's not weird.
No, that's the standard,
the flat space black hole
behaves that way.
Just look at a Schwarzschild
black hole in flat space
when the horizon side
becomes smaller and smaller
the temperature become
higher and higher.
That's a standard
feature of flat space.
AUDIENCE: It must
be the other way.
If you have a huge
black hole, then why
is it that the beta goes down?
That seems bizarre.
Maybe it can't also
be standard, right?
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Both things you said
are correct and are important
but there's something
more elementary
you're not pointing out.
You're pointing out the higher
order of important things.
But there's one lower order
important thing that which
is not yet pointed out.
AUDIENCE: There
are two solutions
of the same temperature.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
In terms of the temperature
this is a [INAUDIBLE]
So if you look at
the given temperature
they're actually two solutions.
So for any given temperature
there are two solutions.
Say T greater than
T min so this is
for the beta smaller
than beta max
means that T greater than T
min There are two solutions.
And then we have to
label them so let's
very imaginatively call this
one the big black hole and then
this one the small black hole.
Because this one have a
larger size and this one
has a smaller size.
So this corresponding
to the r0 of those two.
So you have two
black hole solutions.
One have a larger radius
than the other one.
So we have big black hole
and a small black hole.
And now this is
an important thing
you mentioned that for
the small black hole
the temperature when
you decrease the sides
the beta decrease.
That then means the
temperature increases.
So this as I said
it's like an entropy.
So if you lower
the entropy somehow
your temperature increases.
So when you increase
the temperature
you actually lower the entropy
for the small black hole.
A small black hole
you go like this.
Go like this.
When you reduce the sides,
you reduce the beta,
means you increase
the temperature.
But this is actually the
standard Schwarzschild black
hole behavior in flat space.
And this just tells you have
[? a lack ?] of specific heat.
So this is a situation
we understand.
This is a situation
we can come up
with a flat space, a
Schwarzchild black hole.
And it make sense why it's
happening here because here
roughly is order r.
Because the r is
the scale here so
the maximum location where the
maximum is controlled by the r.
So this region corresponding
to sides of the black hole
to be much, much smaller
than Ads curvature radius.
So when something
is much smaller
than the curvature
radius what you do see?
Hmm?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, flat space.
Yeah, it just like even though
we live in the curved universe
but we actually see flat space
because of course our scale
is much more than curvature
radius of universe.
And a similar key thing here
even though the black hole
have a size much smaller than
the curvature radius of Ads
they essentially behave
like flat space black hole.
And so that's exactly what
you see for the flat space
black hole.
And indeed, in a
more interesting
is this big black hole,
the [? interesting ?]
is a big black hole.
And the big black hole when
r0 increases the temperature
increase.
So this is the right way.
So this is indeed the standard,
just positive specific heat.
You can check it has
positive specific heat.
So this is indeed what you'd
expect from a thermal system.
And so this is indeed what you
So now we are encountering
an even weirder situation.
We not only have so more ideas.
We're not only have black hole.
We actually have
two black holes.
So what's actually described
with the field theory
at finite temperature?
So what does this really mean?
Number two is a
black hole solution.
Now let's look at
the number three.
So now let's look at
what are the indications
those solutions.
So first thing you
can just guess.
So what do you think what these
three solutions should mean?
If you believe this,
duality has to be true.
Yes, so that the
game we play here
is that you believe that
the duality is always true.
And then whenever you see some
phenomenon, the gravity side,
you say this, I
try to integrate.
I try to understand on
the field theory side.
And it makes sense and then
we just carry out the guess
and check it, et cetera.
So what would the
three solution mean?
Three gravity solutions, or
in principle for example,
for a temperature at here
we can have three solutions
all have the same temperature.
What would this mean?
So the simplest guess
is that it tells you
that for CFT and the ST
minus y at this temperature
there's three possible phases.
There's three possible phases.
It's just like
water, ice, or vapor.
There's three possible phases.
Now, the interpretation
is clear.
Then we should just find.
So to decide what is
the right solution then
we should find what?
That's right, we
should find the phase,
find the one with the
lowest free energy.
And then to decide which
is the right one then
we just need to find the one
with the lowest free energy.
So now recall that the partition
function the field theory
side should always be
identified with the partition
function on the gravity side.
And then this side the
partition function by definition
is minus beta, the free energy.
[? Seems ?] like
going more and more.
that's weird.
But on the gravity
side we write this
by saddle-point approximation.
We integrate over
all possible field
on the gravity side weighted
by the euclidean action,
and the leading order in the
saddle-point approximation
you just evaluate it.
You just evaluate it on
the classical solutions.
So now you can just equate them.
You just need the
free energy must
be equal to se to
the to the [? Ic. ?]
So this is just the same
principle we discussed before
on how we just apply it.
So now if we believe
the duality and we
believe with some of
the [? lamicks ?] then
we should just find the
solution with now just SE.
So we should calculate the
euclidean action for all three
solutions and then we find
the corresponding free energy
for each of them, and then
the one with the largest, SE,
will correspond to the one
with lowest free energy.
Then that will be
the stable solution.
And the other phases presumably
will be unstable or not stable.
just like in the standard story.
So this conclusion was drawn
from some of the [? lamrick ?]
itself.
But what will be nice we can
actually draw this conclusion
without using thermal dynamics.
So we say, so this
[INAUDIBLE] was
drawn to identify this
with the free energy
and then we say according
to the sum of dynamics,
and then we should choose the
one with the lowest energy.
But will be better
if you can actually
derive this thing
from the gravity side,
and you can and for
a very simple reason.
So this also follows
from the standard rules
of saddle-point
approximation as follows.
Oh, I forgot to
write on this board.
So when you evaluate
this [? possible ?]
so when you evaluate
your integral
you're in the saddle-point
approximation,
so normally you are instructed
to add the contribution
of all saddle points.
So the fact that you have
three different solutions
it tells you have three
separate saddle points.
And then just from
the standard rule
of the saddle-point
approximation
you just need to add
all of them together.
So you add the expression SE,
you evaluate the thermal Ads.
And the expression,
SE you evaluate it
as a big black hole,
and then you add the SE
to the small black
hole, et cetera.
OK, you add all
of them together.
And now each action
is in exponential.
And as I said,
they are weighted.
All this action are
weighted by n square.
Because the action is
always proponent to law
of [? Newton ?] and the law of
newton is [? proponent ?] to n
square.
So there's a big parameter
in the exponential.
So the saddle is not just SE
dominates in the large N limit.
You just add three
exponentials, which one
is the biggest will dominate.
Because each one of them is
proponent to n square and n
goes to infinity.
And n goes infinite means it's
greater than the other guy
by a tiny bit.
in the prefactor of n squared
they will become predominant.
So we see that the sum of
the [? lammicks. ?] Sum
of the [? lammicks tells ?] us
we should define the smallest
free energy and then that
statement can be essentially
derived if I don't
know that statement.
I can actually derive that
rule, say finding the smallest
free energy, just by using
the standard saddle-point
approximation from
the gravity side.
So this is a nice
consistency check.
This a nice consistent
check that the duality
which we believe to be
true should be true.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So the one thing
I don't totally understand
is that, so say that you
give me this Euclidean
integral over metrics
on the gravity side.
So the idea that there's really
only three contributions--
because we found three solutions
with a particular temperature--
how do we know that there
aren't any other solutions?
Like, how do we know there
aren't any other terms that
were not accounted for?
PROFESSOR: Oh yeah,
there are three--
so this is a rule of the
saddle-point approximation,
you find the saddle-point.
So you find the solution
of the equation of motion
with the right boundary
conditions and these
are the only ones.
Yeah, and then of
course, each of them
include the fluctuations.
This is just the standard
saddle-point approximation.
Any other questions?
So now the task just
boils down to-- yeah,
let me just emphasize
here-- yeah,
so now, the task just
boils down to find
what is the lowest free energy.
OK?
So now it's 3-- no, it's 4.
So now, let's try to decide
which one is more stable.
So first, let me just emphasize
SE is proportional to the 1
Newton-- 1/G Newton.
And then it's always
proportional to N squared.
OK?
Because 1/G Newton is
proportional to N squared
if you translate from
the [INAUDIBLE] language.
And now, if you vary the
free energy for them--
for this-- here let me call
this-- thermal [? gas and ?]
AdS, I always just call
it TAdS, OK, Thermal AdS.
I think, yeah, just-- the
shorthand is just thermal AdS.
So for the thermal AdS,
this is actually 0.
This is actually 0.
So thermal AdS is the free
energy-- I should say this way.
SE is actually the
0 times N squared.
And then you can have
fluctuations then
that can contribute to the
order and to the power 0
[? contribution ?].
So the 0 in this-- 0 is simple.
It is because, when we go
from the [? pure ?] AdS
into the thermal
AdS, essentially
we just changing the
global structure.
OK?
We just make the Euclidean
circle so for the pure AdS,
when you go to Euclidean space,
the tau have infinite size.
And then when you go
to the thermal AdS,
we just make the tau
to be a compact circle.
So you have not changed the--
the solution is identical.
The solution is identical
go to the pure AdS.
Just the global structure
is different in terms
of the periodicity of the
Euclidean time circle.
So now, if you vary
the classical action--
so if you're reference
point is that the pure AdS,
the classical action is 0.
And then, for the
thermal AdS will be 0.
OK?
Will be the same.
It would be the same--
the classical action will
be the same as pure AdS, OK?
So [INAUDIBLE] order N
squared, but then you
can have fluctuations
which contribute.
And the fluctuations
is to the-- yeah,
so the fluctuations
can be interpreted
as the, say, the graviton
symbol [? and ?] division
from the symbol, graviton gas.
OK?
And so, say, in the
themal AdS sites
essentially, have a
thermal gas graviton.
And there, free energy
is independent of N
because they are
the fluctuations.
And just as usual,
whenever you can
see that the fluctuations
there, they're
independent of a
coupling constant.
Is this clear?
AUDIENCE: Why is
the first term 0?
PROFESSOR: Hm?
AUDIENCE: Why is
the first term 0?
PROFESSOR: The first
term is 0 because this
has the same classical
solution as the pure AdS.
AUDIENCE: The pure AdS, then,
has a nonzero [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, that's a
very good question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I will-- yeah.
Wait a few minutes.
I will talk about
this more precisely.
It's a good question.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Let me just tell you
the answer first,
and then I will
say a few things.
Any other questions?
OK.
And then if you calculated
the Euclidean action
for the big black hole
and the small black hole,
you find that they are
always greater than that.
It's always larger than action
for the small black hole.
And this is some number, nonzero
number, times order N squared.
So this is always the case.
We also [INAUDIBLE] way for you
to calculate in a few minutes.
But I will not do this
explicit calculation here
because it takes some time.
So there is a simple
way, physical way,
to understand this-- to
understand why this is true
because this is a free energy.
So this tells that the free
energy of the big black hole
is always much more-- is always
smaller than the free energy
of the small black hole.
This is not a precise
way to understand it,
but it is a heuristic way-- is
that if you look at these two
solutions-- so these
two solutions have
the same temperature,
but the big black hole
have a larger size.
When you have a larger
size and the entropy
is proportional to the
area of the horizon--
and the entropy is much
higher, so the big black hole
has much higher entropy
than the small black hole.
And so you choose-- you
would expect that this should
have a smaller free energy.
But, of course, you have
to do a precise calculation
to really check it because
their energy is not the same.
Their energy is
also not the same.
Yeah, but this is a
heuristic way to understand.
Anyway, so you find
that the free energy--
so you find the Euclidean
action, or the [INAUDIBLE],
is always much--
is always greater
than the small black hole.
And that is good.
That is good because
that tells you
the small back hole
is never dominate
because you always find
something bigger than that.
And the small black hole have
a [? lack of ?] specific heat.
That's not something you
want because our Field
Theory definitely have
quality of specific heat.
Our Field Theory definitely
has quality of specific heat.
So that tells you
that this is never--
can be low-- that would
be a dominate phase.
So now, if you
calculated a number--
so now if you look at
the number explicitly--
So what you'd find actually--
so you also have-- let me just
first tell you the results, OK?
You find there exists
a temperature, Tc,
which is greater than
the minimal temperature.
Then, you find that the-- when
you're smaller than the minimal
temperature--
Yeah.
Right.
OK.
So when your T is smaller
than the minimal temperature--
oh, no.
No.
T is smaller than Tc.
So you find that there
exists a Tc, which is greater
than the minimal temperature.
So let me just say this.
So when T is smaller than
T minimum, of course,
there's only thermal AdS exists.
And, of course, that
would be the only phase
which can describe the
Field Theory result.
But, now, there exists another
temperature [? then, ?]
within T, smaller than--
greater than T minimum
and smaller than Tc.
Then, you find that the SE big
black hole is smaller than 0.
And the thermal
AdS, essentially,
by definition to be 0.
So that means that
the thermal AdS
will have lower free energy.
So in this range, the
thermal AdS will dominate.
And when T is greater
than Tc, then you
find that the big black hole
now has a positive action
and [INAUDIBLE] dominates.
So if I draw this--
and then there's a Tc
and there's a T minimum-- so
this is the temperature axis.
So here, of course, you
only have a thermal AdS.
But within this
range, the thermal AdS
dominates over big black hole
and the small black hole.
And when you're above, then
the big black hole dominates.
So you actually have
a transition at Tc.
So below here, it's
just thermal AdS.
And then you have a
transition from thermal AdS
to the big black hole at Tc.
So a quick side remark.
How we-- how would
you find this result?
So this would be the result
if you calculated the-- so
you just calculate
the Euclidean action.
You compare them.
That's what you would find.
So any questions about that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you ever get
the small black hole phase
at all somehow artificially?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you can
always get artificially.
Yeah, artificially, always.
Yeah.
And let me not go into that.
So now, let me just say a few
remarks, say, in finding SE.
So when you find the
Euclidean action,
you find it is always divergent.
It's the same thing as
what we encountered before.
If you calculate
the whole action,
you have to integrate the--
over the-- essentially,
the volume of the AdS.
But the volume of
AdS goes to infinity
at-- near the
boundary, essentially,
you always get infinity.
So in order to get a
[? finite ?] answer,
you need renormalization.
So when you do renormalization,
essentially, you
put the [? cut ?] off and
then you subtract covariant,
the local counter terms.
You put a cutoff.
And then you subtract covariant
counter terms at the cutoff.
And then you get
a finite answer.
Then, you take the
cutoff to the boundary.
So we will not go
through this procedure,
but it's something you can do.
But there's an
alternative shortcut
to not go through these.
Or you can just subtract-- just
calculate the Euclidean action
for the cutoff, then subtract
the value of pure AdS.
So if you calculate
the pure AdS,
you will find the answer
is also divergent.
You will find the answer
And you just subtract it.
And then when you
do the subtract,
you will find the
difference is [? finite. ?]
And then you find the
difference is finite.
And this is a slightly
simple way to do than that,
but we also not do this
because, still, you
have to calculate Euclidean
action [? and such. ?]
So the synchron-- shortcut is
to assume thermal dynamics.
That's what we did last time.
Because you can find the
entropy density very easy.
So entropy density--
did I erase my--
so the entropy density
is just, essentially,
the area of the horizon.
So the entropy-- right now, it's
actually the total entropy, not
the entropy density because
now we are [? almost here. ?]
So the entropy would be--
and size of the sphere
will be r0 to the power d
minus 1 times omega d minus 1.
Omega is the volume
of a unit sphere.
And then divided by 4 pi 4GN.
So this is the
entropy of the system.
And you can express this
in terms of the temperature
because r0 is a
function of temperature.
r0 is a function of temperature.
If you invert this,
you can imagine r0
is a function of temperature.
So you have-- essentially
you have entropy
as a function of temperature.
And-- Hm?
AUDIENCE: d minus
1, what's that?
PROFESSOR:
[? Formula ?] d minus 1
is the volume of
the unit sphere.
So you know the entropy.
You can just use the formula
S equal to minus F minus T
divided by T to--
so you can also
write this as minus F r0,
partial r0, partial T,
et cetera.
And then you can
integrate this equation
to find the-- to find
F as a function of r0
because we know how the
r0 depends on T from here.
So you just need to
integrate this equation.
So this is a simple
exercise because now
you just need to do an
integral of some function.
And then you find omega
d minus 1 divided by 16
pi GN, r0 d minus 2 minus
r0 d divided by R squared.
You get actually a
rather simple answer
if you do that integration.
So we have chosen the
integration constant so
that when r0 equals
to 0, this is
0 because r0 equal to
0, if the black hole has
0 size, essentially,
[? there's ?] no black hole.
And then we have
chosen the free energy
to be 0 for the
[? no ?] black hole.
So this free energy,
again, should
be interpreted as the
difference with the pure AdS.
So for the black hole-- this
is the black hole free energy
because, by definition,
this way, the pure AdS,
you just have 0.
Any questions about this?
So now you see here,
clearly, this expression.
So now this is a
free energy now.
This is not the
Euclidean action.
So they differ by the
amount [? assigned ?]
in my convention.
So now you see that there
exists r0, critical r0.
F black hole is greater than
0 Free energy is greater
than 0 for r0 is smaller than R.
So you can write it as formula d
minus 1-- so let me just write.
Yeah, you can put the omega--
the r0 to that [? out ?]
for the overall factor r0.
Yeah, put d minus 2
out, and this just
becomes 1 minus r0 squared.
So you find that the free
energy is greater than 0.
But r0 is greater than 1.
That's greater
than the-- so this
is greater than the
value of the thermal AdS.
And the black hole
is smaller than 0.
The free energy [? smaller ?]
than 0 become great than R.
So the r0 is somewhere here.
So r0 is somewhere here.
It has to exist above
the-- it's somewhere here.
This is r0.
This is this r0 critical
[? as you go ?] to R.
This is r0 critical
[? as you go ?] to R,
somewhere here.
So it's always a big black hole.
And you can find out what is
this critical temperature.
So the critical temperature is
just the beta evaluate at r0
equal to R. And then
you can find out
that this is 2 pi R
divided by d minus 1.
Just using this formula
you can find out it's that.
So now I emphasize that
this is a phase transition.
And this is not only
a phase transition,
this is actually a first
order phase transition
for the following reason.
So in our unit, below
here, the free energy
is 0 times order N squared.
It's 0 times N squared.
But about here-- well,
actually, above Tc-- at Tc,
the free energy is
exactly equal to 0.
So [? r0c ?] is
equal to R at Tc.
There's a free energy.
It's exactly 0.
So at Tc, the-- a big black
hole and the thermal AdS
have the same free energy.
So they can exist together.
And above here, then the free
energy of the big black hole
is some negative number times
order-- times N squared.
So your free energy
has a huge change.
So essentially, the first
derivative of free energy,
is discontinuous across
the phase transition.
So this is actually a first
order phase transition.
So this is-- yeah, let
me just emphasize that.
So this is a first
order phase transition,
with the free energy equal
to order N to the power 0
when T is smaller than Tc and
some nonzero number times N
squared.
Well, T greater than Tc.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: When r0 is equal
to R, then F is equal to 0.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Then, why is the-- oh.
PROFESSOR: No, the derivative
of F should be discontinuous.
No, F is continuous.
No, this is a definition of
the-- for the phase transition,
the free energy is
always continuous.
And then the free-- so the
first derivative here will
be proportional to N squared.
And you can check-- Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So the point is-- OK,
so just see if I understand.
So the point is that
it's discontinuous
in the limit of
large N or something?
I mean--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
Exactly.
So let me emphasize.
So this is N goes
to infinity limit.
Is there any other questions?
So we see there's a lot
of [? rich ?] story when
you go to the sphere.
And, actually, there's
a phase transition.
And the phase transition
roughly [? adds to-- ?]
the black hole size
is the AdS radius.
Exactly the black hole
size is AdS radius.
And this is, more or less, what
you expected because that's
where the physics become
nontrivial because when
the horizon is much, much
smaller than the black hole
[? size-- ?] than the
curvature radius, as I said,
just should reduce to the flat
space black hole and et cetera.
Yeah, because the curvature
radius is only scale here.
So now, let me make
another remark.
Now, I erase this.
I think it's OK.
Yeah So you should
actually check yourself.
So below Tc, the F
prime is always 0.
When you take the
derivative, it's
always 0 at order N squared.
Let me, again, write this
answer, 0 times N squared.
So you should check that
the first derivative of F
is discontinuous.
AUDIENCE: So F itself
is not discontinuous?
PROFESSOR: No, F is not
because the F is 0 precisely
at T equal to Tc.
So F is equal to 0.
And the-- Yeah.
So the reason the first
derivative is discontinuous
is very clear because
below Tc, this is 0.
So the first derivative
is 0 times N squared.
And above Tc, the
derivative is the derivative
of the free energy of the
black hole at I equal to r0.
And, clearly, the
derivative is nonzero.
At I equal to r0, the
derivative is [? nonzero. ?] OK?
And so you see,
they're discontinuous.
So since physics only depends on
the [? dimensionless ?] number,
R times T-- So large R,
small T-- large R at fixed T
essentially is the same as
the, say, large T fixed R.
It can only depend
on the ratio of them.
OK?
It depends on the
product of them.
So you can either think
of-- you can either
think you fix the
temperature, you
increase the size of the sphere.
Or you fix the
size of the sphere,
you increase the temperature.
[? In ?] fact, the same
is to increase this guy.
And this is essentially the
limit going to the flat space.
It's going to the R to the T.
If you take R go to infinity,
you go to a [? theory ?]
on R d minus 1.
So we see that the
theory on R d minus 1
is mapped to the high
temperature limits
of the theory on the sphere.
So essentially, just
corresponding to the 1
point for the
[? theory ?] on the sphere
and this infinite temperature of
the [? theory ?] on the sphere.
So that's why, as
we said before,
because there's no scale here,
the [INAUDIBLE] temperature
from here is essentially
the same in the flat space.
And in particular, this is
described by a big black hole.
And this is exactly
what we see before
because when the black
hole become very big,
then you can approximate
it to a plane
because, locally, it's
like a plane [? anymore. ?]
And the spherical horizon
is just like a plane.
And then you go to
the black plane--
you go to the black hole
with the flat horizon.
AUDIENCE: Why are the phases
only dependent on R times T?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because
this a CFT and this
is only dimensions number.
It can only depend on them
through this dimensions number.
There is no other scale.
Good?
Other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So on the
side of the CFT,
what are the different phases?
I didn't-
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: What are the different
phases on the CFT side?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's what
we are going to explain.
So now, we have to describe
the black hole story.
Or now, we have described
the gravity story.
Just by looking at
the gravity size,
we saw there are
three possible phases.
At low temperature, you
get this thermal AdS phase.
At high temperature, you
get big black hole phase,
and then there is a phase
transition between them.
And then, also, you have
unstable small black hole
phase, which never
appears as a stable phase
at any temperature.
So, now, let's try to see
whether we can understand this
from the Field Theory side.
What does this mean from
the Field Theory side?
Why somehow-- if I, for example,
put [INAUDIBLE] on a sphere,
do I expect such kind
of phase transition?
Does this make sense?
Oh, by the way,
I should say this
is the-- so this is called
a Hawking-Page transition.
So this is called a
Hawking-Page transition.
So remarkably,
this was discovered
in 1980-- I think '81
or '82, almost 20 years
before this AdS/CFT conjecture.
But they already
figured out that there
is a phase transition.
They were-- so they were
looking at the black holes
[? and ?] AdS, and they said,
oh, there's two black holes.
But there's also some AdS.
And then, somehow,
there's some kind
of phase transition
between them.
But because they don't
know the Field Theory,
they don't know this
should correspond
into some kind of
Field Theory system.
But they figured out this
gravity story essentially
in 1981.
Now, let's explain what
should be the Field Theory
interpretation of
this-- The Field Theory
explanation of this.
Physical reasons for
Hawking-Page transition.
So now, I will
consider a toy example.
So I won't consider--
so [INAUDIBLE]
on the sphere, that's a
little bit too complicated.
But I'm going to
consider toy example.
And you will see,
from this toy example,
that the physics behind this is
very simple and actually, also,
[INAUDIBLE].
So let's consider you have N
squared harmonic oscillator--
free harmonic oscillator.
So let's just
imagine you can take
them to be different
frequencies-- [? let's ?] just
even for simplicity-- or
for the same frequency.
Say, omega-- I have some omega,
which I just take to be 1.
Doesn't matter.
So just consider N squared
free harmonic oscillator.
So I claim when N-- when
N goes infinite limit,
this system have the
same phase transition--
have exactly the same phase
transition described there.
So, now, I will explain.
So first, let's
look just at-- this
is a system we know how
to solve exactly, so let's
look at the spectrum.
So this is total spectrum, the
total energy spectrum of this N
squared harmonic oscillators.
So let's call the
0, the ground state.
So let me normalize the
energy so that the ground
state have energy 0.
And then you can excite
one harmonic oscillator,
and then you have state of 1.
Yeah.
Actually-- Yeah,
have state of 1.
And you can have two harmonic
, oscillator et cetera.
And then you'll have many
harmonic oscillators, say,
of all-- then, you're going
to have almost every harmonic
oscillator excited.
And then you have energy of
order N squared, et cetera.
So now you have to imagine a
slightly nontrivial condition.
Now, you have to imagine a
slightly nontrivial condition,
which this is the
only thing [? reach ?]
beyond the harmonic oscillator.
Yeah.
Actually, I just realized this.
I slightly oversimplified
the story a little bit.
Yeah.
Yeah, let me say this way.
Let's consider 2N
harmonic oscillators.
So let me arrange it
into two matrix, A and B.
And they are all free.
it doesn't matter.
For this purpose, it doesn't
matter how many harmonic-- just
imagine I have arranged
them into two matrices,
so I have two N squared
harmonic oscillators.
And then I can excite them.
But, now, I have a condition.
So I have a condition, which
is analog to the condition
of the gauge invariance.
Instead, I want all
the states to be
the trace singlet
created by A and B.
You have A, B, et cetera.
So A have N squared creation
and annihilation operator,
and B have N squared
annihilation-- creation
and annihilation operator.
And then you can
act them-- then,
you can [? accurately ?]
form the spectrum that it is.
But there's a-- but also I
need to add a gauge invariance
condition.
It's that the state
[? acted ?] by A and B
have to be SU(N) singlet.
And SU(N) is the conjugate.
Just imagine A and b
transformed under some SU(N)
[? join representation. ?]
And they
have to be the SU(N) singlet.
So equivalent statement say that
the trace A and B-- the order
state has to be
created by operators
inside the trace, single trace
or multiple traces, et cetera.
So is this clear?
AUDIENCE: So one thing.
So A and B are operators?
Or they are--
PROFESSOR: They're operators,
harmonic oscillators.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Imagine you have two
matrices under-- and two
harmonic oscillators
that form two matrices.
And each of them have N
squared harmonic oscillator.
And if I just say they
are free, then you
don't even have to think
about the matrix structure.
AUDIENCE: So the only thing,
I'm confused about the matrices.
So are the matrices acting on
some [INAUDIBLE] So in other
words--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Let me be a little
bit more explicit.
[INAUDIBLE] Think about
the foreign system.
The Lagrangian 1/2 Tr
A dot squared, Tr 1/2,
Tr B dot squared minus 1/2
Tr A square 1/2 Tr B squared.
So this is a free
harmonic oscillator.
So these are two N squared
free harmonic oscillators
with frequency 1.
So if I don't impose
this singlet condition,
this is just a purely
free harmonic oscillator.
But now, I [? require ?]
all the state--
and so SU(N) transformation--
[? yeah, you can act them. ?]
But now, I impose the
condition that they will have--
they should be SU(N) singlets.
So they can [? create ?]
it by A and B, et cetera.
But they should
be SU(N) singlet.
Good?
So now one thing
you can convince
yourself is that because
of the trace condition--
so if you think about the
state of energy 1 or 2,
et cetera-- so as far as the
energy is order N to the power
0, so as far as the energy
does not scale with N,
you can check yourself the
density of state-- the way
you can-- the degeneracy
of those states
will always be of
order N to the power 0.
So this is a fact.
You can convince yourself.
And when you go to the
energy of order N squared,
then you can check that
the density of state
become exponential
of order N squared.
So the reason for
this is very simple.
So the reason for this is
very simple heuristically.
So the reason for
this is very simple
because if you have a state
of order 1, which does not
scale with N, means there's
only order 1 states-- order
1 oscillators are excited.
And then, of course,
the density of state
will be independent of N. And
if you do have energy of order
N squared because each
of-- each oscillator
has a frequency of 1, and then
you have energy N squared.
And then that means order N
squared oscillator is excited.
And then you have order Ns--
if you have order N squared
oscillator excited, then how
many ways you can choose them
to construct the [? state of ?]
energy order N square and that
[? exponential ?]
of order N squared.
So imagine each
of the states, you
can have N possible oscillator
to act, say, for each of them
for twice.
Then, you have 2 to
the order N squared
probabilities of doing that.
So that's where this
[? exponential ?] order
N squared come out.
So this is a fact.
You should try to
convince yourself
if it's not obvious to you now.
So the reason I add this
singlet condition is for here.
If I don't add a
singlet condition,
then there's some
kind of independence
here, which I don't want.
There can be [? log ?]
independence.
Yeah, just-- yeah.
So this makes [? your ?] story
a little bit [? convenient. ?]
Oh, so now-- yeah.
We're running out of
time unfortunately.
So now let's consider
the free energy,
which, roughly, you can
consider as integrates
of all possible states with
this weight factor and times
the density of state.
[INAUDIBLE] because
the free energy
sum of all states,
minus BH, and the sum
translated into the integral
with a density of states.
And then that
translates into that.
So naively-- so we
always consider--
so our beta is always-- does not
scale with N. That's order 1.
It's always order 1.
So if you look at here
naively, only state
of energy of order
that's not scale N
will contribute significantly
because of this suppression.
Because of the thermal
suppression, say,
if you have energy
of state of order
N squared, then this
is a huge suppression.
Then, they should
not contribute.
Then, they should not make
a visible expression--
a contribution to
your free energy.
Expect, except when those states
have a huge density of states.
So except when those states
So, here, we see those
states have actually
order N squared
density of states.
So that means, in here, in that
integral, you have beta times
order N squared-- something of
order N squared and then times
something positive
of order N squared.
When you can see the
contribution of the state
of energy of order N squared.
So when this factor
dominate over this factor,
then the entropy will overwhelm
the thermal suppression.
And then, such
state will dominate.
And that precisely happens
when beta becomes small enough.
Because when beta
becomes small enough,
when you got the high
temperature, then
beta decrease.
So eventually, this
will overwhelm this one
because the beta will decrease.
And that's precisely the
Hawking-Page transition
we'll see.
So at low beta-- at big
beta or small temperature,
thermal-- this one dominates.
And then, the [? V ?] would
be of order N to the power 0
because only state of
order-- energy order zero
will contribute.
But the beta-- when beta
is sufficiently small, then
the [? log ?] D(E) minus BE
can become greater than 0.
And then the order N squared
states will dominate.|
And then you find
the-- then, you find
the [? partial function ?] will
be [? exponential ?] of order N
squared.
And that's precisely what we see
in the Hawking-Page transition.
So I emphasize that
physics here have
nothing to do with the
details of the system,
only related to the large N
and to the density of states.
So if you have interactions,
if you have more complicated
system, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
As far as your [INAUDIBLE],
this phenomenon will happen.
This phenomenon will happen.
And so this is the essence of
the Hawking-Page transition.
We will stop here.